[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
with that i'm going to turn it over to
uh
jim parady the robert metcalfe professor
of writing and media studies
who's going to introduce our today's
speaker so jim
thanks scott um welcome to the
comparative media studies colloquium
at mit i think there's
a number of people from mit
and outside of mit i'm jim parady a
faculty member of
comparative media studies and writing
our talk this afternoon
is creating space for balance indigenous
knowledge in western science
two-eyed seeing in environmental justice
and media
our featured speaker is patricia solis
this year's mlk visiting scholar
also executive director of the maliceae
nation conservation council and a member
of the malasea tribe
of indigenous people whose lands lie
along
the saint john willistock river
and its watershed along both sides of
the u.s and canada
the river empties into the bay of fundy
that's a
very tremendous river
miss solace is an experienced tribal
policy administrator
an environmentalist and educational
planner
a recording of this talk will be posted
friday uh
at the cms website two-eyed seeing has
been a contemporary concept
by of two indigenous mac
elders in cape breton canada through the
use of
indigenous oral tradition elders
dr albert marshall and dr murdana
marshall have participated in many
recordings of their concept and teaching
their appearances at conferences across
canada and the u.s
have provided many venues to share their
work
in our presentation this afternoon
patricia
will feature clips of the two elders
speaking and provide some perspective
on how their work could be brought
forward in discussions of
environmental justice and media
patricia welcome and it's all yours
willie when professor paradis and
i just want to say quay hello nel de lis
patricia salas
i am from tobik first nation which is a
military community in
new brunswick canada and it's a great
honor to
be with you here this evening and i look
forward to
to wear discussion i did prepare
a powerpoint um that i will ask
for it to be brought up so that i can
share some of my ideas and
thoughts with you this evening
so i had
had the idea that i needed a new
mantra and and that new mantra
is creating space for balance
and in regards to indigenous knowledge
and western knowledge
in the two-wide seeing approach and how
it can apply to environmental justice
and media
i thought that this was you know a very
apt
opportunity to be able to share
some of the insights from
two of the elders who have been leading
the co-creation and co-learning process
that is enabled through adopting the two
white seeing
approach in order to
i guess get started on my presentation
i would ask for the next slide
andrew it's not advancing
not advancing it's showing on mine as a
second
i'm on the second slide on mine yeah um
you may need to unshare and try again it
depends on how you selected the window
when you shared yourself i see i
see
[Music]
does that show any different yes yes
with acknowledgments okay good
yes thank you scott thank you so much
um so as as part of our protocol
we often um start with our
acknowledgements and so in my
acknowledgement
i'd like to give thanks to the mit
graduate program in comparative media
studies
and professor james paradis as my host
faculty member
as well as the institute community and
equity office
that the mlk visiting scholar program
is a part of i'd also like to give
thanks
for the mit native american student
association and alumni
as well as the mit american indian
science and engineering society
as well as supportive colleagues friends
and family
who are supporting me and of course
helping me to
achieve what i can in this uh wonderful
year
of although it's it's virtual
i'm still very very glad and grateful to
to be a part of this program next slide
please
further acknowledgements as part of
protocol is to give thanks to
the waters the ground the trees
the plants the crawlers the swimmers
the winged ones the two-legged and the
four-legged
as well to give thanks for our levels of
creation
which is of course above us
below us and what is on the surface
as well to acknowledge and give things
to
the seen and unseen as well as our
ancestors
all of our ancestors past
present and future
i'd also like to give acknowledgement to
the spirit of songs
dances languages and our dreams
and being the uh one of the mlk scholars
i i feel it's very important to
always draw upon the legacy of dr king
and the very um the very essence of so
much of his wisdom
is based on many of the
notable quotes that have been captured
as part of that legacy and
i'd like to share just one um with you
as a way to ground
this work and and the work that i do
he said make a career of humanity
commit yourself to the noble struggle of
equal rights
it will make a greater person of
yourself a greater nation of your
country
and a finer world to live in
next slide please
as well i would like to provide the
acknowledgement to
the land acknowledgement mit land
acknowledgement
mit acknowledges indigenous peoples as
the traditional stewards of the land
and the enduring relationship that
exists between them
and their traditional territories the
land on which we sit
is the traditional unseated territory of
the wampanoag nation
we acknowledge the painful history of
genocide and forced occupation
of their territory and we honor and
respect the many diverse
indigenous peoples connected to the land
on which we gather for time
immemorial next slide please
as well i want to give acknowledgement
to the protocol
and as i've outlined many indigenous
nations follow many levels of protocol
such as ceremonial protocol spiritual
protocol language protocol cultural
protocol
community protocol internation
protocol and interpersonal protocol
acknowledging protocol knowing protocol
and honoring protocol is an essential
element to establishing respectful
relationships
relationship building on protocol is a
culturally sensitive and appropriate way
of demonstrating care and concern for
well-being
following protocol is meant to ensure
inclusion
gratitude and acceptance at the
forefront of recognizing the spirit
of all that is brought together and
provides protection
from what may be negative
next slide please
so delving into the subject at hand
too wide seeing i did just want to give
a little bit of context before we also
delve into
some of the youtube references that i'm
going to share with you tonight
two wide seeing approach in redressing
systemic discrimination
in environmental racism and injustice
is based on on the idea that there is a
combined vision necessary to understand
the plight of life today
some willistic elders or meliseed elders
have noted
that what happens to our relatives the
four-legged the swimmers the flyers the
crawlers
those seen and unseen will happen to us
too
what humans are doing to their
surroundings is having a devastating and
lasting impact to life
climate change does exist and that it is
man-made climate change is not only
about
impacts to humans but to all life and
that is a
story about life and death and there is
great grief
sorrow and anger in the telling of this
story
further that we understand that humans
are but
one of our but only one species of 8.7
million
it is going to take a reconnecting a
vision
between two competing world views to
fully understand
where we are at and what needs to change
knowing how to use the best of both
next slide please
so at this point i'm going to share with
you
are two elders that
i'm going to reference in the next part
of the presentation
can we play the first then second
link please [ __ ]
m
in english it means that um
to be mindful of
maintaining that interconnection
interdependency within
with with our with all of creation
we have to do it on a daily on a daily
ritual basis
and yes let's use the word prayer
we use that format of not just
acknowledging but expressing our
appreciation to what she has given us
and and also to remind ourselves as to
what our responsibilities are
of ensuring that join our little short
stay
here in this physical plane
we have to somehow we have to find a way
and be mindful as to how we go about
exercising
our inherent responsibilities of
ensuring
that no action that we that we will take
will ever compromise the ecological
integrity of the area
nor compromise the cleansing capacity of
the system
because our overall objective is to
ensure
that the next seven generations will
also have the same opportunities as we
have
and hopefully better opportunities than
we have i've not just been able to
sustain themselves
and and harvest the gifts from the
creator but also be able to enjoy
and learn from from from her just like
what our ancestors have
i've learned from her
i'm regina marshall i'm a retired
associate professor
i'm a grandmother and a
great-grandmother
i was born in 1942 in waikato
i left waikogma at one year
and moved to the big centralization
party that the federal government
planned
and i was caught up in that well when
you're invited to a party you're not
going to say no
i grew up here was educated at the day
school in the
indian day school until grade 9 i think
and then i went to arishet for a year
or two then i transferred to
saint joseph's convent in mabu
after high school i got married and
everybody was gone whole to marry me
because i wasn't yet pregnant so
my father was delighted when i asked him
holy mackerel when he said
because in those days you only need high
school to survive
and get married as soon as you can
before you're in the family way
i decided to go back to school and i
went to a
teacher's college to have that early
childhood program
but when i found out you cannot teach in
a regular
school program with that certificate i
think it's only three or
something like that then i moved on to
unb
and there i received my bachelor of
education degree
and then from there i moved to uh
i went down to harvard and received my
uh masters in administration social
planning and social policies
and from there i realized the greatest
need
for eskasoni was to entrap the language
to make it static so it doesn't erode
any longer
so i went to saint thomas university
and graduated with a
with a certificate program of teaching
the average indigenous languages and
training teachers and then i
worked for the went to work for
university of
cbu and was there for 18 years until i
took sick
i've always been concerned about the
language
i decided to prepare my
education endeavors working towards and
around language
and i've been doing that although my my
master's
is in administration at the university
where i worked
that wasn't the discipline i was in
so i first year i did curricula
and the next year after i made the
curriculum
they asked me to teach it
so uh i taught
yeah but at the end i was so beat
i had five classes
to fill the uh need
it drained me out of my own energy and
out of my own spunk
not that i'm bragging i'm the savior of
the world
but i was able to open some of their
minds
when i lived had to replace me with
three people
because they drove me mad completely met
i haven't left capric much except for
education
i i enjoy cape breton
i enjoy the water i was born
that far from the water like a couple
hundred feet
and the ball was lit near water
and when i go somewhere like calgary or
and there's no water around i feel very
uncomfortable
and unable to sleep and you know because
i
miss that air not the waves
but i miss that air coming from the sea
but capernaum has been my favorite spot
in the world
not having so much choices but
the places where i have been up excuse
me
alvarez drives me and draws me back to
great britain
i like the hospitality and the
familiarity of the blades and
um we lived in boston
for a while like all mostly arcade
burtons do
but we came home because i wanted my
children
to speak their own language
and to recognize the most precious thing
in the meanwhile life
and that's family i want them to
experience
their aunts and uncles and cousins and
how are they how they're connected to
them and i
i give my greatest credit to my
grandfather
he was my mentor even when i was
into marriage he was still my mentor
and my aunt jesse gidor the medicine
woman
those two had the greatest impact in my
life
uh and my other aunt aunt catherine
who taught me the hieroglyphics
and another on taught me how to tell
stories and
preserve legends and
all that zuma language has no
prepositions it has no war daughter
it has no gender there are seven
pronouns
that you use consistently
and there's uh five tenses so it's
um that's a giant art of five tenses
they have the past person the future but
they're missing out on the
healing tents and they're missed out on
the spiritual
tents and they're both self-healing
when you were a little kid and you have
no television radio or a tarry or
anything like that
you uh you listen to stories and you
tend to sit around the fire
after supper and everything well in the
meanwhile
there is also a thing a supper dinner or
breakfast
you eat when you're hungry your body
your body dictates your your
your you it does you don't dictate your
body
and so when you want to go to the
bathroom you don't wait for the b parade
you go
i see one
so you we have these stories different
people
i would come in in the evenings and
visit and tell
stories and i received a lot of stories
from listening to my own grandparents
and my own aunts and uncles
the stars were your guiding point
there the constellations were your
calendar
if you look up in the sky you know what
seasons by the way
the constellations are arranged
they're also your guides for travel and
stuff like that now take for instance
the constellation of the dipper
now that's a long stretch to teach you
uh
seasons of the year months of the year
and uh how the how the beer is situated
is we tell you what time of the year it
is
whether it's late spring or or mid
summer or beginning of fall or
by the way the constellations are
arranged and the equinoxes and the salts
play an important role and you're
determining the movement of the earth
and so you sort of know these stories
because you know them through people
telling them
but as you grow up you don't know really
what
why they tell you the stories until you
yourself
began to take up an interest in in the
sky or night stories or astronomy
then you begin to piece these pieces
together
these stories attached to this
constellation
and vice versa i have no one to think
but my family
these stores didn't
didn't come automatically it was through
experience and
remembering and because you can't when
you when a story is told to you and it's
interesting
it's hard to kick it out of your mind
you know it'll stay there it's engraved
there
so those two elders dr
albert and dr medina marshall
along with cheryl bartlett worked
through
cape breton university in sydney nova
scotia
canada to create the institute for
integrative science and health
and that institute lasted
from 2006 to 2012
and the institute offered a science
degree
program since professor bartlett has
retired
and the program has transitioned into
another department
there is still a growing segment of
science faculty and universities
across canada that have sought to adopt
the two-wide seeing learning approach
to enrich their solely western-based
programs as a way of sharing this with
mit
i am hoping that there that there are
those amongst you
that seek a similar vision of learning
that can create not only a higher level
of success
but also a greater degree of
connectivity and learning
that will enable enable superior
learning paradigm
development and research in creating
a better world for all next slide please
so we have another two um
segments on youtube if we could play
one then the next andrew sure
[Music]
that's how it started the communities
the elders were concerned that there
were not
any students from their communities
going into the sciences
[Music]
two icing really is it's and has to be
your guiding principles as to how one
should live
while you are here on this undeserved
[Music]
through i'd seeing as brought to us by
elder albert marshall migma elder
descasoni
is recognizing that there are different
ways of looking at the world
and maybe two of those ways are the
western scientific way
and the indigenous peoples or the
aboriginal people's way
and that two-eyed seeing refers to
finding the strengths
in both of those the western and the
indigenous
and mindfully bringing those strengths
together
drawing upon the deep understandings
that they represent
the strengths of each and bringing them
together to work together to go
forward on this planet together i feel
that what we learned as first nations
people in your own identity miguel
is valuable i also believe that the
concepts being brought on by europeans
is also available in today's world and
you try to bring those two
together and and look at it through two
i'd seen that
both are very valuable and both
can be can be achieved our ears are
poisoned our rivers are poisoned our
forests are pretty much gone
and the animals are are extinct even as
we speak
with this two-way scene we very quickly
realize and see
that science science is not going to
save
the environment or the natural world but
rather rather a change of a change of
attitude
change of mindsets i see the strengths
of western science as being
the ability to look at
the physical world see the patterns
within it
and take those patterns apart and find
the mechanisms
or try to search for the mechanisms that
that bring those patterns into existence
and then on the basis of that
reconstructed understanding
try to improve upon our material
existence often
for humans in this world i see the
strengths of the indigenous peoples on
the other hand of
also seeing the patterns in the world
but rather than taking them apart to
reconstruct them
it's more of a working of patterns
within patterns
in other words a weaving of yourself and
your understandings into the
world in which you live i think one of
the most
exciting and useful ways to teach
science would be to use one of the
methods from science
itself which is the compare and contrast
why can't we educate our science
students
as to what the mainstream way of doing
science is
and compare it in contrast with another
way
of doing science from an indigenous
perspective why can't we put them side
by side
and use them to help a student develop a
better understanding of what mainstream
science is
and what other perspectives on science
are that's a scientific method compare
and contrast
basically the education system has
taught us to
to observe every knowledge we get
without actually
without actually questioning it or
looking at it from another perspective
why do we think that we can teach by
focus on on
the one thing when the whole of human
consciousness is not a focus on
one thing it's always a back and forth a
scanning of the environment and a
compare and contrast
and a past and a future within the
present
with me my identity as i was growing up
i didn't know any other identity because
i was being trained in mig
i was trained in a language and in the
language i embedded all of your your
or your oral traditions all your moral
and all your everyday life
your history is involved in it because
when you went to bed at night without
the
competition of television and atari and
everything else you had stories you had
stories about your own history
you had stories about about everything
that
it was required to make you into a
better human being
part of the struggle of anybody i don't
think it matters who you are is
to ask yourself and to learn who am i
so if an educational system uh ignores
part of who who you think you are uh
simply because it doesn't include your
people's understandings as for example
if the science curriculum does not
include any of the understandings that
canada's aboriginal peoples have with
respect to the land that they've
occupied for thousands of years
then that ability to develop a
well-balanced and deep understanding of
who you are
as a young aboriginal in canada today is
going to be denied
our journey here is not meant for one
one perspective or one consciousness to
get us through
we we all need each other so the
the lessons that we are trying to put
forth now is
to to our young people it's going to be
much more expedient
if we can take the best of whatever
tools the white man has brought forth
and the tools what our forefathers have
left us with
this tool i've seen is valuable
when you when you pick from the two from
you when you pick from
two worlds and try to join
co-join those two is i find it very
difficult
but i know it has to be done
i know in you can i can i can crawl
into my culture and say oh that's all i
need
to survive in this world i also know
that you need the white man's education
to uh to survive in this world
and be happy and
and i think the white man also needs me
to what i what i have to offer
we have a challenge ahead of us to bring
to the attention of that educational
system
the western way of looking at things is
but one way
paraphrasing chief dan you're saying we
should take the instruments of the white
man
his tools and his education and we'll
incorporate them with ours
so we can create a better world for
everyone
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so as we know that there are many who
want to utilize
two wide seeing as a tool that can help
themselves and others understand
the indigenous worldview and how it can
help create a better path to
environmental justice
indigenous justice and human justice
there is a strong connection being
developed between two-wide seeing
and seeing more equity in relations
between
all life on earth i am going to share
with you
two practitioners both indigenous both
in two different parts of this country
both striving to use this tool in their
work
and both present their stories and
thoughts based
on the two-wide scene next yep
okay
good evening my name is evan tesla adams
and i'm so happy to
present some ideas to you tonight around
the the very simple concept of two-eyed
seeing which
most of us are are lucky enough to have
um
these two masks were uh collected here
in the north of british columbia one is
in
the louvre in paris and uh one is at the
canadian museum of civilization and gets
you know
and one is blind and one is sighted and
it might represent
uh maybe us looking at you or looking
forward and back
now this is a fish it's called a soul
you've probably eaten it it's very
humble fish
it can look in two directions at once
it's a it's a bit unlike
um human beings who have binocular
vision but they usually look
those eyes look in the same direction
from but from slightly different
positions so is two-eyed seeing or
looking forward and looking back
uh whimsical is it avant-garde is it
post-colonial
maybe it's part of being the pluralistic
multicultural
success story of being in modern canada
maybe this is reconciliation and maybe
two-wide seeing is the ability to look
inward and outward at once
maybe we can self-reflect maybe we must
look ourselves in the eye
see the truth and be able to sleep at
night
and maybe two-wide seeing is
hopeful or beautiful or
it's the idea of balance the idea of
getting back
to optimism and to beauty maybe
two-white seeing
is about love and family and
togetherness
strength acceptance maybe it's about
prosperity
of both or of all
now two-eyed seeing is a concept that
exists
in indigenous culture and there is a
very famous academic
mr albert marshall who talks about
two-eyed seeing
as learning to see with the strengths of
each other
and together looking one eye with the
strengths of indigenous knowledges and
ways of knowing
and with the other eye the strengths of
western knowledges
and ways of knowing and that together we
can
look forward so here's another way of
seeing 1492
two eyes coming together christopher
columbus
arriving in the often island in the
caribbean he was lost
looking for india and that
arrival set off a great time or period
of exploration for europeans
this is a painting of captain cook
when he was killed by native hawaiians
on the big island of hawaii in 1779
and aboard that ship was a midshipman
named george vancouver
george vancouver came to the coast of
british columbia
again and again and again uh here's his
his
um a portrait drawn when he came to my
mother's village
1792 uh cortez island of course my
mother hadn't been born yet
she was born about uh a kilometer from
here and so for
me captain vancouver is very real
and we have very many stories about
those this is my great grandfather
tom charlie adams who was born in 1860.
this picture was taken of him in 1930
when he entered
hospital with dementia and he's alive
he's blind so he doesn't he doesn't he
didn't i hear open his eyes
as he walked about and he lost his
vision to smallpox
this is canada this is canada
1867. it looks different from our image
of
canada today i know when you imagine
canada in your minds it's not this
picture
and of course i'll point out the two
solitudes of english canada and
french canada uh we were there too
but can you imagine canada with
indigenous roots
well part of its indigenous roots were
the indian act a federal act
born in 1876 140 years ago
that took great
measures in controlling the lives of
indigenous people
these are my parents i'm sitting in my
dad's lap
and one of my sisters died when i was
about five years old
she was accidentally shot to death by
the boy next door
and i tell that story uh because i knew
even then
even as a five-year-old that communities
and people were meant to be organized
to help each other that that wasn't
supposed to happen and my family who was
quite wounded by that
deserved help and we should be organized
enough to help
so the challenge for us today in canada
is that health outcomes between first
nations and other canadians
is different it's unacceptable it's
unethical
and it's sustained unsustainable and so
what shall we do just to point out dr
camara jones in undoing racism describes
in a gardener's tail that a gardener
notices that pink flowers
grow taller than red flowers and she
thinks pink flowers are better
forgetting that she's planted them in
different parts of the garden one in
rich soil
and one in poor soil and so we discussed
the
the idea of the social determinants of
indigenous health that the quality of
health the quality of life the length of
life
the lack of suffering is tied to poverty
to education and to housing
of course for all of us but for
indigenous people it's also related to
culture
and to self-determination that the lack
of determination
can change one's health here are two
aboriginal medical students who
graduated just a few weeks ago
in my teaching at ubc we discovered that
31 out of 32
aboriginal medical students had racist
experiences
that were strong enough to discourage
them from continuing and we had to talk
to them about staying in their programs
and thus the idea comes forward if we're
going to face
the inevitability of a racist experience
perhaps we should be armed for racist
experiences
and that doesn't mean that all of you or
all of us are racist
simply that the reaction the idea of
resistance
and resilience is one that we must live
with
when i moved to bc with my new medical
degree and i went to saint paul's
hospital
i went into the doctor's lounge i was
very proud i looked exactly like this
within five minutes the security guard
came up to me and he said i'm i'm sorry
sir one of the doctors has reported that
there's an indian in the doctor's lounge
and i laughed and i said yeah you better
get used to it
part of my work is to work with
aboriginal populations one day we had a
chief who was fighting for the return of
an infant who had died
the chief coroner said by law i'm
allowed to keep this infant body
for as long as i see fit and i can
remove parts of that body and keep them
in order to determine a cause of death
and the chief slammed his fist
on the ground or on the table and said
we know you think you're in charge
but we think that's our baby
so to get where we need to go we may
need to fly in a different way
i showed this to an elder and she said
oh yeah the
male eagle flies up down when it is
having sex and i said oh that's
not quite what i wanted to say and she
said yeah that's a sexy eagle thank you
[Applause]
and just so they know where about that
10-minute mark that we asked you to
point out
ninda rebecca hi my name is rebecca
shall we the language you speak
fundamentally shapes your worldview and
everything that goes along with it
and this concept is specifically
amplified
when it comes to indigenous languages
indigenous language
weaves its way through every aspect of
who we are as
people from how we interact with the
physical world how we build our
communities and how we carry our culture
forward
and with that comes a unique perspective
and it's that perspective that i'm going
to try to create for you so that when i
introduce the concept of eduoptamonk of
two wide seeing you'll understand
why it's so important so to begin a
study
published in psychological sciences
called two languages two minds
broke down grammatical tools that
situate
actions in time they showed photographs
to
english and german speakers and ask them
to describe what was going on in them
so for example they showed a woman
walking in a parking lot
english speakers said this is a woman
walking
whereas german speaker said this is a
woman walking to her car
they showed another photograph a man
riding his bicycle
once again english speakers honed in on
the action and said this is a man riding
his bicycle whereas german speakers
needed to add a destination to complete
their context
even though that destination wasn't
featured in the photograph
this is a man riding his bicycle to the
library
or to the supermarket and what's
interesting
is that english marks events as ongoing
we're very action oriented in our
language
so if i'm writing a poem when my spouse
calls and he asks me what i'm doing
i'll say i'm writing regardless of the
fact that i had stopped to answer the
phone
german simply doesn't have this feature
and so it's interesting to see
the two world views these languages
carry even though they have a common
root
so what happens when you have a group of
people with a language that has no
common root but must
operate within a completely foreign
framework specifically
how do indigenous people find success in
a colonized world
now the saying things get lost in
translation
rings truer than you might imagine when
it comes to indigenous languages
this is megama territory and many of you
might have heard the word
gelasi to mean welcome that's what it's
used for but the literal translation of
the concept equates to
i'll do my best that's a much more
nuanced and meaningful interaction
in this moment a person-to-person
contract is being agreed upon
think about that in this moment
i will try for you so
language so language isn't just
something
we use to get our points across as i
said it's woven into who we are
as people and our notions of a broader
identity
so robert thomas no relation wrote about
that
that broader identity and he called it
peoplehood when referring to indigenous
peoples
now the term peoplehood is a little bit
odd so i'm going to break it down for
you
peoplehood differs from identity in that
it not only
encompasses the individual identity but
how that person
ties it to a larger collection of
peoples and how that in turn connects
them to other people within that
collective
so for example i don't speak migamo and
i grew up off reserve but i still
identify as a mega maw person i'm still
within the concept of a mega maw
peoplehood and that in turn
connects me to somebody who grew up on
reserve and who speaks the language
and it's getting a bit complex so please
bear with me
peoplehood is made up of four things
territory sacred history
ceremonial cycle and language each
thread informs the other you can't
address a single aspect of it without
looking at the whole
think of a spider web if you clip a
single thread that anchors it the whole
thing
starts to collapse so the migamo
language
for example with its unique
characteristics gives
meaning to a sacred history which
dictates the use
of the land which is crucial to the
appropriate execution
of a ceremonial cycle which in turn
is performed in many of the languages
that those ceremonies encompass
so firstly that is a direct quote from
my m.a so i'm going to take this moment
and feel vindicated in my decision to
pursue another arts degree
and secondly indigenous peoples are
complicated and complex
imagine centuries ago when we were
writing the treaties and the language we
were communicating in
encompassed how we would use the land
how would we carry our culture forward
how would we develop relationships
with the settlers and colonizers now how
much of that was lost in translation
when they
were recorded in english and french
so i digress but remember those four
strands
language ceremonial cycle territory and
sacred history the best part about
peoplehood is that it is tremendously
flexible
we can swap out and alter some of those
strands without
compromising our status as indigenous
people
so once again i'm going to use my lived
experience as an example
you already know i don't speak migamo
and that's because through residential
school
my primary language threat has been
replaced
with english and french so if i go to a
ceremony that's conducted
entirely in the mega man language the
significance of that ceremony
might not fully resonate with me because
i won't understand the full scope of
what's being said but that does not
diminish who i am as a migma person
furthermore there are many migamot
people who are practicing catholics so
even though they smudge and they dance
and they drum and they sweat
they also go to church and pray in the
migamo language and that does not take
away from them they have woven another
set of ceremonies into their
ceremonial threat because being an
indigenous person
is a lived experience it's there's no
spectrum whereby somebody is more
or less native than somebody else any
arguments over authenticity
are us internalizing a history of
colonialism that has created
rubrics and tools to measure our
ethnicity
and blood quantum has nothing to do with
it the fact that my mother is non-native
does not take away from the fact that i
am a mega mall person
so with that said i'm going to check in
with you guys
language shapes your world view and is
one of four
aspects that create an indigenous
peoplehood an indigenous understanding
of knowing of how the world works so
when you look at the picture that i'm
trying to paint for you
you're going to understand what you're
looking at so here's the picture
indigenous peoples are the fastest
growing demographic in canada our median
age is 28 years old compared to that of
43 to the non-native world
and what that means is you're going to
see more of us in your classrooms in
your workspaces and in your public
spaces the world is going to have to
learn to interact with us
in ways that are more meaningful and
significant than what they have done in
the past i don't need to elaborate for
you all to know
we don't have the best history so what
that's the question i always get asked
how does this apply to the real world
i work in student services in education
i act as a go-between for the native and
non-native world
i advocate for students who have a hard
time speaking up about themselves
i coach faculty on how to have
appropriate cultural supports and yet in
spite of what i try to do
sometimes the effects an indigenous
student feels are too great
and they leave to go home and it's not
that they're not
smart it's not that they aren't capable
of doing the work it's just that this
world doesn't get them our protocols our
concepts of time
our ethics etc are just different
and it doesn't mean we can't communicate
with your world we've been doing it for
the better part of five centuries
it's that we ask that you now try to
communicate with our world and it is at
this moment
that i introduced the concept of
wide seeing it was introduced by elder
albert marshall
two-eyed seeing tanks takes the
strengths of both a colonized world
and both an indigenous world and asks
that the user
see through both lenses simultaneously
to find
success it is the migma understanding of
the gift of multiple perspectives
to see multiple contexts simultaneously
for example you see nova scotia
nouvelle cass canada we see
mega magi traditional territory turtle
island
it's not either or it's both
at the same time two-eyed seeing
was originally introduced to build
greater capacity for stem programming
for indigenous students and
post-secondary institutions
and is now being adopted nationally by
organizations and institutions who are
interested in trans-cultural
collaboration
two-wide seeing implies responsibilities
for reciprocity mutual accountability
and co-learning it's what we tried
to build our treaties on we want you to
know about us
and we want success in this world but we
are no longer willing to give up our
world
to do it and you might be asking
yourself why would i go through
so much trouble to indigenize the
institution for such
a small number of students in the answer
my friends is beautiful it has been
shown it has been proven that when
institutions
implement indigenous pedagogy and
learning styles
students across the board benefit native
and non-native
because we recognize the multiple
contexts and paradigms that learners
learn
through our ways of teaching have
traditionally been more universal
and more inclusive so
with all of my academic speak and
concept introduction i bring it back to
the elders
who always tend to say it best
with regards to education and
relationship building
according to albert marshall the
foundational basis
of any relationship is an exchange
of stories so as a storyteller
and as a poet i will leave you all
with what i do best a poem
entitled
i lost my talk said rita joe for me i
was never given the option to know to
feel the flow of the words as they
rolled off my tongue
giving me the lyrics of how our world
was sung my perspective was spun using
the threads of both your world and
theirs left to cobble together a spirit
from rags and tears
painfully aware that i was different
through hard work and determination i
found my indigenous articulation a
compilation of two ways
makes up the sum of me you have two eyes
that you only have one view
your way as best you would argue
centuries of being in position to subdue
those who would aspire they say the sun
never set
on the british empire and because we
recognize the hubris that defines your
story
we have both a sunrise and a sunset in
our territory
with my heart and eyes i have a
completely different view the
consequence of my skin
comes in an entirely different hue don't
you see
although you represent us we think very
differently than you because we see the
world not through one set of eyes
but through two thousands of years long
we were independent proud and strong we
belong to this earth
the way power belongs to money and
privilege to birth we put our
communities first
but then came the fleets filled with
those you would ironically define today
as come from a way to invade every inch
of our world
to break our spirits and pull the
threads that would unfurl us to catch
the way you speak
but this is not a poem for the retelling
of a one-sided history
each of our worlds has their strengths
yours is in power it gets to eat its
cake and define race it has the ability
to unapologetically take up space if
societal progress
is linear this society is top tier terra
nullius
as though we were never here it must be
nice
to be so confident this society is
ubiquitous built on reified rubrics of
tradition and rhetoric
your notions of diversity are ad hoc in
nature and afterthought feature
to an immovable structure but this is
not a conviction
nor an acquittal just the voice coming
from an eye trained to be critical and
if you push the two sides of our venn
diagram together you'll get our circle
we were never meant to be static like
the rivers around us we shift and change
and remain dynamic
we bring something to the table that is
able to change your world view and show
you what we are capable of
that a lot can come from a holistic
concept of the earth
you are not a plague nor we a curse
or a problem in need of a solution and
we've got to rid ourselves of the
spiritual dissolution the dilution of
our treaties
written to share this land and i ask
that you
understand that we are the experts on
what
we need don't feed us your good
intentions carefully laid apologies will
not get you an historical exemption
we plan our actions for the next seven
generations and we invite you to do the
same
open your other set of eyes take a pause
and start breathing welcome to the world
of 2ica thank you
[Applause]
so in terms of these practitioners and
and the two people that we just saw
you know it brings up a lot around what
can we learn
what do we know how do we learn
who can benefit how how does
how we learn matter referenced in both
of these presentations was the
connection to where they came from
the need for sharing stories the ability
to connect
experiences and lessons learned the
richer the opportunity to learn
from other perspectives through a lens
that allows for incorporating vision
and spirit and information and to be
able to communicate from that space
is a path to creating balance
in dealing with issues of environmental
justice as i have been through the
as i have been through the class that i
am a guest lecturer in
with professor paradis and john it has
allowed a new door to open
to discussing how convergence of
extraction
environmental justice and media studies
is powerfully related next slide please
recently in our comparative media
studies class
professor macarena gomez barris
gave a presentation and referenced her
work the extractive zone
which contains the following comment
before the colonial project could
prosper it had to render
territories and people's extractable and
it so through a matrix of symbolic
physical
and representational violence therefore
the extractive view sees
territories as commodities rendering
land is for the taking
while also devalorizing the hidden world
that came
from that sorry while also
devalorizing the hidden world that form
the nexus of human and non-human
multiplicity this viewpoint similar to
colonial gays
facilitates the reorganization of
territories
populations and plant and animal life
into extractable data and natural
resources for material
and immaterial accumulation
two wide seeing is a way of creating the
space for balance in the systemic
systematic approach to extraction
and the creation of wealth as
acknowledged and as we sit here
through this pandemic we must open two
eyes and see we cannot sustain
future generations through willful
blindness
next slide please
to wide seeing as related to the media
we have the opportunity to create
innovative
and meaningful messages of collaboration
through adopting a two-wide seeing
approach
we can build new pathways new protocols
new relationships based on respect for
ourselves and each other it is time that
we put down the fear of not knowing
and developing our abilities to
instinctually know
what we need to create sustainability
and equality for our young
we can learn and grow in accepting the
need for systemic change
the need for systemic security and
well-being
as impetus for innovation and research
we can truly go within and see the world
through clarity
and keep moving towards holistic
well-being
we can become teachable media has a role
and a responsibility to informing and
allowing opportunities to educate and
inform about two-wide seeing
it will be worth the effort
next slide please
and in conclusion there is one last
brief
clip that i wanted to share with you
welcome to c2019
i'm very honored to open this conference
with
a bridges theme award to elder albert
marshall
and his late wife mardina albert
you are my trusted guide for how i
should look at
embrace and also engage with the world
around me
through you and through medina
and your writings and most importantly
your spirit
we receive guidance and mentorship on
how to set aside personal ambitions
to set aside pain and darkness
and turn to trusting and to assisting
i want to thank the canadian evaluation
association for
giving me this opportunity to be part of
a tribute
uh to someone who had the wisdom years
ago to
understand that we need to respect and
appreciate
the other and this wisdom
is today more valuable than at any time
as we the people in the world tend to
drift apart
at the moment and this is exactly the
time
where we need to stop for a moment
and look at what
combines us what what we can blend
together to take the best from all of us
in order to improve what we do our
practice
and the world toy scene
i think really has played an important
role
in increasing the understanding of the
indigenous
ways of knowing and doing as well as
indigenous ways of evaluating
by saying that
we're looking at the strengths of the
western world with one eye and the
strength of the indigenous world
another eye it really becomes a
non-threatening way
to engage people
in evaluation and increases
their likelihood to understand that in
fact you can accept
indigenous evaluation practice in a way
that increases
the authenticity
of your work two-wide seeing
allows us to better understand the
challenges that we face
working with organizations and ideas
like blue marble evaluation
this provides us an important principle
to bring forth to the world
and is with great great honor that we
celebrate
this work of elder albert marshall
and his late wife mardina on the work of
two-eyed seeing
i had the privilege of engaging
with elder marshall at the canadian
evaluation society when we discussed
together rights-based evaluation
and what we found in that engagement
was that 2idc informs
all kinds of evaluation including the
work that
i've been involved in over the last few
years on blue marble evaluation
blue marble refers to looking at the
earth
as a whole as seen from outer space
and in our engagement together new
marble evaluation
and two-eyed scene are completely
integrated as is integrative science
so what we have found in blue marble
evaluation and into
what i'd seen is the integration of the
local
and the global is the integration of
theory and practice
is looking across different sectors and
issues to see their commonalities
is to look across artificial boundaries
of
nation states so that what we are
empty attempting to do in creating a
sustainable future
two-eyed scene instructs us is to
combine the human and the natural
on june 21st
of 2017 i went out to fast
and i prayed for the spirits
of these women and girls that had been
misner murdered in new brunswick
i prayed for the spirits of the families
that i would be working with
and and i knew that energy would be
really strong
and that even though the victims they're
no longer here in a physical sense
their spirits are always with us
and so i wanted to approach this project
in a good way
and that meant taking it to ceremony
and in terms of evaluation we look at
how many times we've gone to
ceremony we
talk about the importance of narratives
and the qualitative
um the qualitative feedback from
families not just
the written feedback
and i really owe that to albert and
merdino
they provided me with uh
some valuable lessons
about how
how important our world view is
they val they they taught me to value
who i am and where i come from and why i
am the way i am
they taught me how to value the
territory that we come from
the land the water
and even the different ways we show that
appreciation
through song through dance
through painting and then it doesn't
always have to look like
western mainstream methods
and i just want to say thank you to
albert
for taking his time and his energy to
pray on these things
and to be so wise and to share
and to have faith that these teachings
will go on and
spread throughout mother earth
to everyone
[Music]
so in conclusion i just wanted to close
with another quote from dark dr martin
luther king
jr and he said we have flown the air
like birds
and swan the sea like fishes but
we have yet to learn the simple act of
walking the earth
like brothers elenin
thank you thank you very much for the
presentation patricia
time for um for questions
from
clearly
anyway uh so we can switch our view
here all right
uh scott i'm sorry we sing hands raised
um
no okay
i'm sorry whoever's raised the hand
should feel free to speak
hey so i i raised my hand but i just
wanted to ensure first that there wasn't
someone else who is
specifically in indigenous um
canadian and u.s studies who would like
to ask a question before me
just out of respect no okay thank you so
much for this presentation i greatly
appreciate it as someone who
um works on indigenous communities in in
the middle eastern and north african
region so thank you um this was
one wonderful um i have a few questions
um and wondered if you could clarify um
just um
certain points of of the pedagogy that
that this is advocating for
um and and in one of the videos uh one
of the
uh one of the women she was talking
about
um the um relevance
of compare and contrast as an important
way to approach
um two i'd seen and i'm i'm wondering if
comparison
contrast um unconsciously privileges
western thought as an ontological
approach
that indigenous learning is is always
already
measured against um or or how do you
approach or how do you account for
certain
inherent imbalances in in power
um due to supposed rationality of of
western thought
um and and i just really am curious
about this uh
for my own pedagogy and if you also have
a recommendation for
a repository of of this information for
pedagogical thought i would really
appreciate
you sharing that as well
well ewan thank you i think that's an
excellent question
and oftentimes um
you know folks are folks are wondering
how can we approach this
from i guess the the understanding
that both indigenous knowledge systems
and western knowledge systems
are legitimate
and so one from the outset
understands and i guess we would say
appreciates that one system
is not privileged or or seen as
having higher authority or claim
to um truthfulness
that that the other system does not also
carry that
so so i know that you know
me saying that doesn't um necessarily
address your question
but i know as far as getting the
understandings and the teachings
directly from
you know our elders and and others who
are practicing
too wide seeing that is something that
they would reference
at the outset of bringing forward this
um these ideas and
and i think it's really important that
you know
along with understanding the
legitimacy and the place
and um the acceptance
of that credibility that comes with
appreciating
both knowledge systems is
is an important step for folks to take
because you know as we know we've
we've had a very long time of one
system being elevated um to
to almost the point of the other system
um completely disintegrating and so
through this approach the idea is that
through revitalizing indigenous
knowledge systems
we are providing and creating the space
for balance essentially
um because it is through that it's
through that exchange it's through the
reciprocity of
of um you know providing ideas
and observations um in
regards to a particular um
you know purpose or or matter
that it is in that is in that
cross-pollination
of that discussion that you really begin
to get the
um i guess the abundance or the
fruitfulness
of what that can bring into a
conversation that is otherwise
you know pretty um pretty pretty set
in terms of what is established
knowledge
on the matter so and as far as
um providing resources um i do just want
to say that you know i have been working
with
um mit nasa and mit
aces for us to create a reading list
actually we we don't actually have that
as as a resource and so we are going to
be doing that and and
as you could probably tell i have a lot
of uh references that
uh i'm i'm compiling already but we're
we're doing it as a
as a collective exercise so that
you know different different levels of
uh let's say
audience and readership for the younger
hip
crowd and perhaps uh you know those that
uh are are more aware of
you know contemporary references that
that we're going to have a range
of of what's available for materials and
and what we can reference
i have a question from the chat but
before i just i want to open it up if
there's
someone in um has a question
among the panelists um
all right so the question from the chat
is from perry and it's a practical
question
how can science writers and science
journalists and reporters find
indigenous sources
to help balance their reporting and
bring two wide seeing into their
journalism well
there is uh i think a number of ways
um first and foremost i would say
you know as as with any kind of
journalistic exercise you develop
contacts
you develop you know references
um i think taking that time to do
some of that foundational research
about who's available where you're at
and the particular matter um you know
is is one um technique
um i think there's another technique and
that is to
actually reach out within
mit to the indigenous community here
we have both aces and nasa that have
you know student groups and and they are
you know always meeting always
interested to have
a good conversation and so you know
if if that is more um practical
to and amenable to you know how someone
can
uh reach out i'd say you know reach out
to
to the folks you may know and they can
often
um provide further contacts or
for you depending on depending on the
subject matter
and we have a question from caroline
jones
i thank you so much for that really
fascinating talk
um and you know i'm thrilled because
i helped through some administrative
funds to
support marisa and jim's class so i'm
really glad that this has has
been such a fruitful exchange i wanted
to know
if you had some information on how
successful the two-eyed seeing has been
as a pedagogy
to draw indigenous peoples into the
sciences
you know as an mit faculty member it
seems like such a vital
vital part of that pedagogy and i also
just wanted to make a recommendation for
a book that i'm sure you know
which to my way of reading would be on
the top of your reading list
which is the phd botanist robin wall
kimmerer's book creating sweetgrip which
is just it just changed my life so
um i'm hoping that you know models such
as her center for native peoples in the
environment which is drawing students
from
all over the u.s uh to do
essentially maybe even for the first
time
uh graduate work and science that they
can take back to their communities
and practice on their ecosystems
it just feels to me like such a
brilliant example
of what you're talking about no for sure
and i really
really appreciate all your uh effort and
support
that is wonderful to hear and you know
in terms of
in terms of success i would say that
uh you you only have to go as far as
your
uh searchable google engine
and put in two-wide seeing and you will
find a number of both scholarly articles
and
other types of references that will
provide
at least foundational material
you know as far as success goes i have
through my
role with the malicious conservation
council
we have been working with elder albert
um
i'd say for about seven years now
and and we have been working to
incorporate too wide seeing into the
work that we do with communities and
with partners
but as well with government and
and it's always so interesting to find
and discover
where conversations can go when it's
based
on this type of an
openness and a willingness to learn from
each other
and truly that's that's you know
um difficult as it is um
that really it it takes some
it takes some openness to be able to
um begin to appreciate what is being
um i guess explained and described
as a way of communicating with each
other and that's why
you know it it's such a wonderful fit
with cms and the ability for
especially the students that are in our
class
to understand and to be able to hear
the indigenous perspective on
environmental justice
and extraction and how that translates
into how they use media and
and media messaging in order to bring
across
their stories their concepts and and
i you know must say it's it's been a
tremendously
positive response for myself
even just you know in these last few
months
that people are incredibly receptive
and and really quite curious
about how to mobilize
um you know some efforts and
collaborations
and that really are so wonderful that
i think are really um providing an
opportunity
for innovation and creativity which is
you know of course the very best that we
can do
well i hope some scientists also are
listening
thank you so much for your generosity
yes thank you patricia um i don't see
other questions
although if someone has one now last
chance um but this will be
this is recorded so it'll be online and
so uh
hopefully many more people will see it
as well um
and again we really thank you for your
um there is a question
there is a pretty good question in the q
a yeah let's go for that i'm sorry i
didn't see that you need to read it out
or
i will do it out loud sure how does
two-eyed scene deal with contradictory
conclusions for example
the indigenous scholar marlene brad
castellano maintains that indigenous
knowledge includes
revelatory knowledge this involves the
belief in the supernatural and things
like dreams and visions
which would not be accepted in
scientific theories
if some indigenous knowledge holders are
creationists for example
how would like seeing reconcile with
this theory of evolution
well i think it's really not the
it's really not the purpose of too wide
seeing
to reconcile irr
irreconcilable differences in viewpoints
i think
more so two-white seeing is meant to
create the space for
a balanced discussion
and and oftentimes you know
folks that are are um
feeling you know that dichotomy and that
opposition and and conflict and view
even even there even in creating the
space
for for those views to
um coalesce and and create a dialogue
i think is is part of the process
and and really providing that
opportunity
to respectfully listen and actually
hear what people have to say
i think i think that is that is the
um that is the
strength of two wide seeing is that
you know no one no one is assumed to be
wrong
and no one is assumed to be right we all
have something to bring to the
conversation
and let's have it let's do it let's have
that
let's have that exchange
thank you thank you for that question um
i hope i haven't missed anyone that i
have by all means
um it well it looks like uh
as as i said it was a fascinating it was
a fascinating presentation and it
generated obviously a lot of
interesting questions and we'll be
having this online so
again so many more people can see it so
thank you for for your effort for for
this
well he went thank you everyone